[Music]
chris at the ballpark chris thank you a
big weekend for enjoying the outdoors
community pools opening up for the
season but just like
many businesses struggling to fill job
positions
victoria saha found that lifeguards
really in huge demand
it's a tough job to do and it's even
proving tougher to find
lifeguards we're kind of playing catch
up from the staff that we weren't able
to hire last year
in addition to the new staff that we had
to hire this year so we're really set
back about a year and a half
and it's not that they're unable to hire
it's the low turnout of interest in
becoming a certified lifeguard that's
causing hiring gaps
that extra step of having to get that
certification and have those skills i
think is making it tough for us to
compete with other
agencies that are hiring right now smith
oversees the pools on the west side of
the valley
in clark county there are 75 lifeguard
positions still open
smith says it takes seconds for an adult
or a child
to drown but for parents if you're with
your child who is under eight years old
you are always required to stay by their
side when at the pool
as much as people don't like see
lifeguards do much because they're just
sitting there for the most part when
they're needed you know they really do
help
lifeguards are required to reach a
person in distress within 20 seconds
i remember there was a little kid who
had gone away from his parents and i
like that was my moment where i was like
oh like i have to react and i like have
to jump in and like grab onto the water
because they were like
they were like starting to go underwater
and i had to like jump in and get them
a reminder of how valuable the work of a
lifeguard is
victoria zaha 8 news now desert breeze
is offering a class to get certified
in june one of the ways they're trying
to entice new applicants is with a low
fee for this
certification and the red cross tells us
they're offering those classes
every weekend